let's start today with inflation now i i
want to approach this from an economic
perspective because i've been getting
dozens of emails from people
wanting an explanation about how
inflation eventually goes away and i've
touched on this a little bit but let's
talk about it in more detail now when i
say i don't want to make this a
political story
there are some political statements i
have to make because there is so much
political misinformation around
inflation there has been inflation high
inflation all over the world some
countries with higher inflation than the
united states some countries with lower
inflation than the united states there
are many in the u.s who want to blame
joe biden for inflation i have found no
evidence that joe biden is to blame and
in fact
the u.s is not at the highest or at the
lowest level of inflation over the last
year this is a global phenomenon related
to a lot of different things that we've
talked about and for those pointing
specifically to joe biden's covid uh
relief package as the reason for the
inflation
remember that donald trump did two such
packages and they were bigger than joe
biden so if that's why you blame biden
you have to blame trump at least two
times as much and none of these people
are so like with the political stuff out
of the way there's lots of confusion
about like how does inflation eventually
go away and
one of the realities about inflation is
that sustained inflation will eventually
reduce inflation and i'm going to
explain to you how that works but when
people talk about markets and cycles
this is actually what we mean we one of
the best there are many examples of
markets that don't work or are kind of
pie in the sky fantasy they don't relate
to how the real world works when it
comes to inflation
ultimately resolving inflation it
actually does work this way so to start
this
let's talk about what is a good level of
inflation or deflation or no price
changes like what would we want
well a really high level of inflation is
bad because people very quickly can't
afford things it's bad for the economy
because things get so expensive that
others don't buy anything so it's bad
for business
it makes it so that people's wages no
longer can keep up with the cost of
living so really high inflation is bad
and we're seeing high inflation at least
by american historical standards right
now
it might seem like well then is
deflation good because if prices go down
people can afford stuff no deflation is
also bad and again the framework here is
uh
the framework is the traditional
understanding of how modern economies
work you could say david sir
the entire framework is crap put it in
the trash and that's a different
discussion but at least in the modern
economic framework
deflation is bad because if you expect
things to get cheaper in the future
you would wait to buy them i mean okay
things you absolutely need you're not
going to say well i won't eat for a
month because food will be cheaper in a
month no then you're dead you need food
but with a ton of different purchases
if you expect prices to be lower in the
future because we are in the middle of a
deflationary situation
you would say i'm going to wait to buy
stuff and when you don't buy businesses
don't have money coming in meaning they
have to lay off workers and now those
workers don't have money to buy things
because they've been laid off so that's
a deflationary spiral that's also bad so
in traditional economics the
understanding is you want a little bit
of inflation a little bit of inflation
is where economic growth comes from
a little bit of inflation is the reason
why people would you're not going to go
hoarding supplies
but you would purchase things if i want
to look at a car
and the car is affordable today the car
is 10 grand and i can afford 10 grand if
i expect the car will be 8 grand next
year i wait i don't buy it if the if the
car is already unaffordable i don't buy
it but if the car is 10 grand today and
i expect it to be 10 500 in a year
that's a pretty good reason to go and
buy the car today so i'm now supporting
the dealership i'm supporting the
manufacturer okay so that's the
framework for why we say a little bit of
inflation is good
um
let's talk about then what happens when
there is inflation
inflation initially creates more
inflation people fear wow prices are
going up they might go even higher i've
got to go and buy stuff now before i can
no longer afford it
that increases inflation even more
and things start to cost more for
workers so the workers demand more wages
and to cover the increased wages the
employers start charging more for the
products and you have an inflationary
cycle
this only works in the short term
because you can only pre-purchase so
much stuff you can only get ahead
before prices go up so long eventually
inflation is going to reduce the
purchasing power for people people
aren't going to be able to buy as much
stuff a great example is like with a
house if you've got a down payment saved
up and you can afford a thousand dollar
a month mortgage
at a three percent mortgage maybe your
house that you can afford is 200 grand
when mortgage rates go up as we see
inflation
you can no longer afford a 200 000 house
because to keep your payment at a
thousand bucks because of the higher
rate now you can only afford a hundred
and eighty thousand dollar house this
then puts pressure on the home seller to
decrease the price so eventually
inflation which takes away purchasing
power starts to make a downward pressure
on prices and that ultimately is what
reduces the inflation now obviously
there's problems with doing nothing
because
in the short and medium term while this
is going on
people start to be unable to afford
things that they need poor people are
hurt the most by this inflationary cycle
so you've got to figure out how do we
deal with that and there's a whole bun
that's beyond the scope of this segment
but there's a whole bunch of things that
governments can do to say well let's
let's figure out how to support uh folks
who can't afford certain necessities
during this period of time
high inflation can hurt business
innovation because it starts to get more
expensive to start a business someone
might say i'm not going to start the
business well it's a business that could
have employed people it's a business
that could have manufactured a product
or provided a service so that's not good
for the economy either and you've got to
figure out how to deal with that
none of this is to pretend that anything
is any worse or better than it actually
is it's to gain an understanding of how
longer term
inflation will reduce inflation in the
meantime
we have to take very seriously the
effect that it has on people the effect
that it has on the economy but for
people who say well what can't joe biden
just like sign something and fix this
issue
in an economy the size of the economy of
the united states
no the answer is no
and um the mechanism that will
ultimately reduce that inflation to some
degree
is inflation itself let me know if
that's clear or if it's not clear
the only subscription streaming service
dedicated to documentaries is curiosity
stream one of our sponsors if you love
documentaries like me
you should really check out
curiositystream they've got all the
newest and best documentary titles tons
of stuff i can't find on netflix or hulu
and curiosity stream is only
a month when you use my link below if
you're looking for those new
award-winning documentaries they've got
them if you're looking for the classics
from years ago they have those as well i
just watched a fantastic documentary
called deep time history which goes into
early
like pre-history
fascinating and curiosity stream has an
app for all of your devices tv phone
computer whether you want to watch a
serene nature documentary on the couch
or check out a juicy political
corruption story curiosity stream has
you covered you can get curiosity stream
for 15 bucks a year that's a dollar 25 a
month only when you go to
curiositystream.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below